how's it going everyone PewDiePie here
hanpan welcome to my very first non
gameplay video it's gonna be a really
boring video just warning you but it's
also an important video cuz I have some
things that I need to say and it's
important because I have things needed
to say oh wow do I sound self-absorbed
anyway the reason why I haven't been
uploading I'm sure a lot of you expect
part 8 of migrant house but it's not
gonna be up for a long time
unfortunately I'm visiting college right
now I'm sure a lot of you didn't think I
was the smartest kind judging from my
pasta solving abilities but there's a
lot of the effort needed to be put into
the college I go to and and I just can't
right now with with my lost finals for
the summer
coming up in the cinema I just can't put
my hobby in front of that right now so
I'm sure a lot of you I'm sure most of
you will understand that and I'm gonna
miss you guys a lot actually but rest
assured I will be back so don't worry
about that if you miss me too much you
can try and reach me on Twitter and I'll
leave the link to that in the
description and if you miss me too much
you can always reward something I don't
know maybe there's a playthrough you
haven't seen yet you can check my
playlist it's also in the description
you guys suck at reading the
descriptions just saying yes I no
offense but yeah that's pretty much it I
hope you have a great month and actually
pronounce that word correctly for the
first time in my entire life month
months whatever
like I said I'm gonna miss you this half
a year since I started making videos
have been so much fun and some much
happiness have come out of it and I'm
just I'm I'm so glad that I got to share
it with so many people I did not imagine
things being this way and I couldn't be
happier about it so thank you guys and
I'll see you soon bye bye